just about to start our parade of
Champions it's called the Irish national
ploughing championships but in reality
it's more a celebration of farming
showing just how seriously they take it
on the island of Ireland the men driving
the tractors have Rockstar status here
there's a sport here as well as a job
all these people are Irish national
heroes over three days a third of a
million visitors inspect the machinery
and the livestock it's all in the blood
and given that Ireland exports 90
percent of all the food it produces much
of it to the UK the idea of a new border
cutting the island in two is a nightmare
there's a real possibility that the
family farm would not survive a harab
races indeed potential may be this auto
farmers indeed some of the large-scale
ones could equally be vulnerable given
their level of indebtedness what the
British government wants to achieve at
this point is vague at best but it seems
to accept the huge importance of Irish
food to the UK politicians use phrases
like the All Ireland food economy which
most people don't understand
in practical terms it's much simpler so
it appears brexit has come down to this
the British government says it's happy
for meats from that cow to pass some
checks through the Irish border but not
sapele that piece of farming equipment
over there and if that appears
ridiculously picky it's also the case of
the British government doesn't seem to
realise that that would be completely
unacceptable to both the Irish
governments and the European Union the
Agriculture Minister turned up to take
questions there wasn't a single British
journalist there there's almost no
attempt to understand the Irish position
terms of the volume of trade from the
Republican ordinarily in the region of
700 million and something slightly less
coming from north salt and the granular
detail of that is you know 10% of the
the milk pool is processed from Northern
Ireland
like 400,000 sheep come sold for
slaughter I could give you a myriad of
statistics so the continuation of the
all-ireland agri-food economy is really
important to us and those politicians
who represent voters around the border
insist that if the UK can't figure out
what it wants it should let Irish people
decide for themselves this is why people
say their failure to agree on brexit
could lead to a united Ireland so the
choices are stark the British government
can either accept the backstop and the
minimal protections that it provides in
order to ensure that we don't have a
hardening of the border or they can give
the people in the north of Ireland a
choice as to which union they want to be
part of do they want to be part of the
dysfunctional so-called the United
Kingdom or do they want to as declared
in the previous referendum remain part
of the European Union the essential
contradiction of brexit remains that the
UK wants to shut itself off from the
European Union while keeping its border
with the EU open any ideas proposed by
the Irish to square that circle have
been ruled out as unacceptable in London
and yet here they're still waiting for
the British prime minister to come up
with something else instead
Lawrence Lee al-jazeera Carlow in
Ireland